[Música]
[Aplausos]
los primeros días estuve pensando en
todas las cosas buenas que podían salir
de venir acá pero después cuando tuve
que entregar una propuesta y pensar en
empezar a desarrollar la charla entré en
pánico corría por la casa dando vueltas
éste era muy difícil pensar de qué
hablar me explico que estudie física en
la universidad antioquia es una tesis el
ruido cuántico después una maestría en
creación literaria escribir una novela
sobre un poco un boxeador y una novela
sobre la violencia después es un
doctorado en estudios hispanos es decir
un campo muy amplio y escribí una tesis
sobre filosofía colombiana es decir yo
sé
yo no soy especialista en nada
entonces llegué a la conclusión de que
lo mío es tomar muchas ideas ir a muchos
campos distintos combinarlos
relacionarlos mezclarlos e incluso
confundirlos de manera que decidí que lo
mejor que podía hacer era venir a
contarles una historia así que les voy a
contar la historia del día que casi
muero y la importancia que cruza la
frontera que ha tenido en mi vida
llega el paso texas en agosto del 2006
para estudiar la maestría en creación
literaria el paso y ciudad juárez son
una sola ciudad dividida por un río pero
este río es la frontera entre méxico y
los eeuu
era muy fácil ir desde mi casa en el
varios onces de heights hasta el centro
de ciudad juárez de yo iba a todos los
miércoles porque el cine era mucho más
barato en ciudad juárez sólo tenía que
bajar caminando por la calle cuestión
del llegar a pasar por el frente de la
biblioteca pública donde pasé muchas
horas tomar están tan hacia el sur
atravesar el centro de el paso que cada
vez parece más méxico llegar al puente
internacional reforma que une la calle
están del paso con la avenida lerdo de
juárez era muy fácil me tomaba 20
minutos y cruce miles de veces en ese
momento ciudad juárez era la ciudad más
peligrosa del mundo
no sé si recuerdan a hace unos 10 años
que la violencia en juárez era
incontrolable sin embargo el paso era
una de las ciudades más seguras del
planeta en ese momento
si a pesar de esto mi vida nunca estuvo
en riesgo en ciudad juárez y virtud el
riesgo en el paso
las fronteras entre el paso y ciudad
juárez a veces son invisibles es decir
las las personas parecen igual a ambos
lados de la frontera el acento es muy
parecido a ambos lados de la frontera la
música que se escucha la comida es igual
en verano el calor es intenso y el sol
implacable en invierno el frío cala los
huesos de la misma manera en ciudad
juárez y el paso sin embargo hay otros
aspectos de la frontera que son
innegables en un lado en sueldos mínimos
son cinco dólares al día y en el otro
lado son cinco dólares la hora uno de
los lados como ya mencioné era
supremamente seguro y el otro lado
supremamente inseguro los habitantes de
un lado podrían ir y volver sin ningún
problema mientras del otro lado tenían
que buscar permisos especiales y no
tenían permiso para pasar libremente al
otro lado
muchas fronteras son tan artificiales
como las fronteras entre los países
recuerdan que hace muchos años se creía
que si un marinero era demasiado
intrépido y se adentraba en aguas
profundas iba a llegar al borde de la
tierra y se iba a caer porque se creía
que la tierra era plana desde luego ya
sabemos que la tierra es plana y no nos
dan miedo navegar alrededor del mundo
bueno todos lo sabemos menos esta
sociedad que se llama la sociedad de la
tierra plana que en este tuit
dice que tiene seguidores alrededor del
globo
la mayoría de las fronteras están hechas
de miedo como esta frontera para que los
navegantes no fueran no se alejarán
mucho de la tierra firme pero muchas
personas se atreven a cruzar estas
fronteras que no son sólo físicas no son
sólo políticas entre países hay muchos
tipos de fronteras por ejemplo el
cantautor al cantautor elvis costello se
dedicó a la ingeniería de sistemas antes
de cruzar la frontera hacia la música y
ganar renombre mundial el tenor andrea
bocelli era antes conocido como el
abogado andrea bocelli antes de cruzar
la frontera hacia a la música también la
autora julia child una de las autoras
más importantes de libros de cocina y
una de las primeras personas que tuvo un
show de cocina en televisión fue espía
de los eeuu mucho antes de dedicarse a
la culinaria y probablemente era mucho
mejor detectando el sabor del veneno que
el sabor del comino en esa época
por ejemplo un grupo de ingenieros que
tenían como trabajo poner en órbita esta
esta estación espacial tener el problema
de que estos paneles solares no se
pueden sacar abiertos de la
de la atmósfera por la resistencia del
aire y encontraron la solución en el
origami el antiguo arte japonés de volar
papel y la solución vino de cruzar las
fronteras entre oriente y occidente
entre los nuevos y no lo viejo entre el
arte y la ingeniería espacial
y llega el paso texas
la frontera más importante no fue la
frontera física que divide a eeuu de
médico o las fronteras que pase en medio
desde colombia eeuu la frontera más
importante fue la frontera intelectual
pasar de la física a la escritura
creativa todavía la pregunta más común
que recibo es como un físico se vuelve
escritor y es porque las fronteras
intelectuales son supremamente rígidas
nos educan para creer que es imposible
pasar de una frontera a otra sin embargo
justamente hoy hemos escuchado a todos
los presentadores como su fortaleza está
en haber cruzado esas fronteras e
intelectuales
es imposible no pensar en el poema de
robert frost mending world
haciendo la pared
el poema cuenta la historia de dos
vecinos que se reúnen todas las
primaveras a reconstruir una muralla de
piedra que divide las dos propiedades el
narrador del poema repite constantemente
que él no ve la necesidad de esta
muralla antes está a cerca de piedra sin
embargo su vecino le repite
constantemente buenas cercas crean
buenos vecinos parece que ese mantra de
buenas cercas crean buenos vecinos está
siendo repetido por todas partes en el
mundo de hoy hay productos tecnológicos
aquí en colombia contra los hermanos
venezolanos que buscan refugio de la
tragedia humanitaria que sucede en
venezuela en eeuu donde vivo
el discurso anti inmigrantes cada vez es
en argumentos más descabellados y más
contundentes en europa
europa está cerrando sus fronteras a los
inmigrantes que huyen de los conflictos
en siria en yemen en el norte de áfrica
sin embargo el espíritu del poema es
otro el narrador del poema le dice a su
vecino antes de construir un muro me
gustaría saber que incluyo y que dejó
por fuera y a quien quiero ofender
hay algo que no es amigo de los muros
yo crecí aquí en montería en los años 80
y en la primera mitad de los años 90
aquí nació mi amor por la física por la
literatura por la matemática por la
filosofía y aquí nació mi deseo de
convertirme en escritor
sin embargo parecía que montería no nos
pertenecía a la narrativa de la
literatura y de la ciencia mundial es
decir en el colegio nunca nos pidieron
que le diéramos un libro de potter y
arias gonzález quien está en el público
o de gaby sánchez juliá 2 o un poema de
raúl gómez jattín tampoco en las clases
de ciencias nos visitaba un biólogo
profesor en la universidad de córdoba un
químico que trabajaba en una universidad
local quizás esa desconexión permitió
que yo creciera sin darme cuenta que
había unas fronteras tan rígidas entre
diferentes disciplinas y parece que esos
bienes sociales de mis amigos dos de
ellos hicieron ingeniería de sistemas
uno uno de esos dos se dedica a la
fotografía y está por aquí tomando fotos
para el evento otro de ellos es el
guionista de cine y televisión uno más
estudió biología en la universidad
nacional en bogotá hizo una tesis de
neurociencia y hoy el profesor de
literatura en corella
lo importante de cruzar fronteras es ir
y venir no es simplemente mudarse al
otro lado y quedarse allá es ir y venir
alimentarse a ambos lados llevar
productos por así decirlo de un lado a
otro y mezclarlos es por eso que hace
unos años escribí una novela que se
llama el infinito se acaba pronto que
cuenta la historia de un matemático
obsesionado con las ideas sobre el
infinito de que el cantor cantor fue
matemático alemán del siglo 19 que fue
el primero en tener una teoría
consistente desde el punto de vista
matemático sobre el infinito
esta novela ahora hace parte de la lista
de lecturas de muchos colegios en
colombia y hace un tiempo la titular me
llevó a recorrer varios de esos colegios
y me encontré con la queja constante de
alumnos que no querían escoger entre
ciencias y humanidades a pesar de que el
sistema educativo se lo exigía es decir
ellos podían evitar ambos lado de la
frontera por el sistema educativo les
decía buenas cercas crean buenos vecinos
incluso en el caso de un estudiante en
cali que me entregó un poema me leyó un
poema inspirado por el libro en el que
reiteraba la que deja por tener que
escoger pero celebraba el libro porque
él le había permitido tener un puente
para ir de un lado a otro sin problema
necesitamos una generación de personas
que puedan transitar entre diferentes
áreas todos los explicas del día de hoy
todos han mostrado el valor de transitar
entre diferentes áreas
necesitamos esta esta generación porque
los desafíos del mundo un mundo
hipertecnológico no son los mismos para
los países del primer mundo que para lo
que para nosotros entonces necesitamos
que sean las personas de aquí las que
entiendan los desafíos particulares para
nosotros no es lo mismo el calentamiento
global o los efectos de inteligencia
artificial en un país como alemania en
un país como colombia imagínense una
generación de políticos que entiendan
cuáles son las amenazas y cuáles son las
oportunidades creadas por las nuevas
tecnologías y que puedan transitar entre
la política y la tecnología libremente y
que puedan construir políticas que nos
defiendan de las amenazas de las nuevas
tecnologías y que nos abran puertas para
participar estas oportunidades
una de las fronteras que crucé al llegar
al paso fue la frontera ecológica
vendiendo viniendo desde colombia y del
valle del sinú donde el verde no da
abasto donde la naturaleza crece por
todas partes
no sé si han escuchado el chiste de que
el bayern si no es tan fértil que si uno
se come un mango esperando el bus y tira
la [ __ ] en el piso al día siguiente
puede esperar el bus bajo la sombra del
árbol
el desierto era todo lo contrario es
decir tú eras no había árboles eran solo
arbustos secos arena y rocas
mi primer día en el paso menos de 24
horas fui a caminar por la montaña
franklin con un compañero de clase
llamado kevin brown
y en medio de la caminata vi una
serpiente la cabeza una serpiente que
salía debajo una ropa y me picaba el
tobillo
me puse pálido se me nubló la vista me
temblaban las piernas un calor me subió
en el estómago y minutos la cabeza
pensé que me estaba muriendo
unos minutos unos segundos después
recuperé la compostura y me di cuenta
que no me había aplicado la culebra
era simplemente una reacción de miedo
la culebra que me perdonó la vida ese
día después investigue es probablemente
una crótalos lepidus que es una
serpiente de cascabel que se caracteriza
por un cuerpo pequeño y muy musculoso y
un potentísimo veneno que mezcla en
toxinas y neurotoxinas
después de del fallido a la fallida
mordida de la cascabel empezamos a
retroceder sin dejar de mirar a la
culebra y la culebra tampoco dejó de
mirarnos ni de mambo leal cascabel y nos
miraba con esos ojitos de amor que se
ven en la en la foto y caminamos de
vuelta al carro y aprendí una palabra en
inglés que nunca se me olvidará
bradley que significa serpiente de
cascabel y pensé bienvenido al paso esta
fue mi inauguración y lo curioso es que
a mi vida corrió el riesgo del lado
seguro de la frontera y fue del lado del
que casi muero fue en ese lado en el que
mis de escritor
por eso los invito a que no tengan miedo
y que surgen los mares que no se van a
caer por el precipicio
y que tengan en cuenta que a veces el
mayor riesgo es quedarse en el lado
seguro muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]